le tableau que vous avez sous vos yeux
est un tableau d'arthur grimaud qui est
un peintre qui a qui est né à saint
louis qui est mort à saint paul c'est un
des grands pas entre réunionnais du 19e
siècle
il représente en fait une branche de
goyave qu'il avait peinte en fait ce
tableau avait été peint pour env le
directeur du muséum d'histoire naturelle
de l'époque qui s'appelait nicolas
brayons et il faisait partie d'un groupe
d'une quarantaine de peintures où il y
avait tous les fruits de la réunion
qu'ils avaient tous été représenté la
même façon on a ici l'idée d'une
planches botaniques c'était assez de la
peinture mais en même temps cette
peinture est là il s'inspire des
documents scientifiques comme les
planches botaniques justement on est là
pour montrer la branche la feuille le
fruit le fruit vert le fruit en train de
mûrir et le fruit mûr et l'intérieur du
fruit que l'on peut voir ici posée sur
le bas du tableau
donc c'est un tableau qui est un tableau
à vocation scientifique mais également à
vocation pictural et décoratives dans la
mesure où il est parti de cette grande
commande qui avaient été faites par
nicolas bréau ce type de représentations
appartient à un jean en fait en peinture
qu'on appelle la nature morte c'est à
dire qu'il n'y a pas de représentation
de personnages il n'y a pas de
représentations de scènes il n'a pas de
représentation de sa d'historique de
cette religieuse de scènes mythologiques
ce n'est pas un portrait est donc ça
appartient aux gens de la nature morte
et on l'a effectivement regroupés dans
cette partie du musée avec d'autres
peintures de nature morte pour justement
évoqué c'est les 5 gens de la peinture
là tout blanc tout le 19e siècle en fait
la peinture à être organisée en 5 jan le
premier c'était la grande peinture la
peinture d'histoire le deuxième c'était
le portrait le troisième c'était les
scènes anecdotique les scènes de
peinture anecdotique représentants des
petites scènes des paysages et le
quatrième gens c'est le paysage et en
femme le 5e jean c'était la nature mans
c'est aussi pour les peintres comme si
en général très peu souvent le cas des
oeuvres de commande
c'est aussi pour les peintres faire une
nature mans c'est l'occasion de peindre
de s'exprimer de perfectionner son art
de perfectionner sa technique de
perfectionner son son sa touche et c'est
en peignant justement des natures mortes
des fruits des objets des bouquets de
fleurs et des tables